[Music]
hi welcome to Chesham psychology and
today is the first day I'm teaching and
I'll be going over why I think
psychology and chests are so related on
how to pretty much keep your nerves cool
during playing it official game and then
I'll show you two of my games and
analyze those by saying how what was I
thinking how did they come to this
decision and things like that hopefully
it will be helpful so I think that this
class is important mainly because
sometimes when you're learning chess and
you're reading comments and you're
watching videos or you're just playing
online you they're like very if you hear
something it kind of clicks and then
that helps your chest level improve
tremendously and that's something that
happened to me and just by thinking more
logically about the moves and by asking
yourself question during the game those
are the things that will help you
improve your chest level so let's get
started so this is a game that I played
maybe about a little over a week ago and
pan-american tournaments I played for
established University chess team and
for the first time we had a all-girls
team which was very interesting but they
actually didn't play any girl anyways so
my opponents I got a chance to look at
what my opponent played right before the
game for a very brief amount of time
because they only gave out the board
pairings about an hour before the game
and I saw that he's a d4 player and I
decided to go and play names o against
him and I didn't have much information
what he would do at this situation
because there are many moves Quincy to
e3 Knight f3 gtav 3580 f3 it doesn't
stop so I wanted to play something that
I was comfortable with and especially
because he was lower rated by maybe
about hundred points I thought that it's
important for me to get into a position
that I'm comfortable with and I know
what I'm doing and so he played Quincy
to Quincy to is the ID main idea is well
white also have control over the center
just thinking about it super logically
if it were my way to move again most
likely white would try to play E 4 and
if Y did get to play efore the next move
would be to try and play e5 Bishop d3
and the amount of pressure that these
Queen and Bishop would have on the Kings
side it wouldn't it simply would be like
suicide to make short castle for black
so there are many different variations
here for black to play there's simple
castle there is C 5 D 5 b6 there are so
many different lines to look at so one
move that I've played years ago and I
thought that it would be good idea to
give it another try in this game is
knight c6 it's a sideline
it it has a very simple idea you want to
fight the center you want to play D 6 e
5 and because after the Bishop is on
before whenever they play a tree you
would most likely exchange the bishop
off so the bishop is not you're not
really planning and keeping this fish on
the board so it makes sense to have your
pawns on these dark squares
neither three is a very common move
you're just defending your d4 pawn d6
I'm following with my plan Bishop g5
after Bishop g5 I thought that's I say
if I've is not that easy to do anymore
because if I 5 there is always there's
always take take and there may be roopd
ones or then this knight is pinned and
it's just really frustrating for me to
just have my hands tied up like this so
that's why I chose to play h6 and here
it's like I'm questioning where do you
want your Bishop to meet you you want to
keep your Bishop on the board you want
to exchange it off if you do decide to
keep his Bishop on the board let's say
which I wish for
so here it is important as we like to
think to start making candidate moves
because most likely this is an unknown
it's the opening that you would just new
every single move - it's not that common
it's not like Lopez the T with new ant
to move 30 so this is important that you
can make candidate news and you can
start eliminating moves so think about
it like this when the bishop goes to h4
usually the best way to start making
candidate moves is to think about checks
then takes then moves with threats
and then so usually by the end of these
three you would have a handful of
candidate moves that are worth
considering and if you can't come up
with something like that then you can
start thinking about some maneuvering
your pieces putting your places in
putting your pieces in better places
making your king safe and just took off
it's some sort of plan or will to just
simply block what your opponent wants to
do so in this situation the candidate
moves are the Tudors you should
definitely consider is Bishop c3 and
move with treads what is how can you do
a move that creates a threat the
simplest one the most logical one is g5
because when you for the g5 the bishop
has to go to g3 now you start thinking
now that the bishop goes to g3 same same
same principles think about checks and
takes again which is Bishop c3 or this
pawn is kind of hanging around here and
it's only being defended by the night
so think about g4 when the knight moves
you just grab a cap on this is something
that you is worth considering but it's
up to you to decide if you want to push
your Jeep on or not I would I would do
it especially because this is such a
strong pawn in the center if my night
isn't d4 then I can start planning on
maybe doing c4 maybe mmm c5 sorry maybe
if I've been opening up this Bishop I
have just it's so you are already
controlling the center is black you
would have so much more opportunity just
after move before move 10 so yeah in the
game my opponent took on f6
I took back with the Queen the idea of
IVA of still stands he played a tree
because I assumed he was also kind of
frustrated with the bishop over there
because you don't know if I'm gonna take
it if I'm just gonna keep putting
pressure on it
take take so now the waited to think
what does white one because it's so easy
to just say you have you have short
cancel right here you can't make a
castle but it's it would be a little
premature there's nothing wrong with it
but if you make a stall you give to
white the chance to start pushing over
here with before gain more space and
then most likely something like b5 and
it would it would just be annoying for
you to do it to have to have to play
that position so in order to take away
the B for what you do
yep this doesn't require that much
calculation it's just something that you
see what your opponent wants to do you
don't let them do it so after a five I
clearly want to try and play a four and
put this night in b3 because it's a
really good outpost so I think that the
move that my opponent should have
considered is b3 just because if b3 if I
do this a4 now you get to play p4 I
can't play Knight a5 93 anymore at Lisa
and it would just be mmm psychologically
I would I wouldn't like to like if I
could have that 19 b3 it psychologically
it's would give me an advantage because
I'm advancing any pieces I'm gaining
more space in the Queen side and I had a
clear plan but in this situation if he
white would have played b-tree then I
wouldn't have then I wouldn't have that
psychological and space advantage he
decided to play g3 because he wanted to
fianchetto his bishop so I have two
options I can try to play the same a 495
93 or I could try and face this Bishop
coming to g2 off with another set of
moves
suggestions
well you also you can't think about it
another way you can't think about where
you want this Bishop to be where would
be the best place for this bishop in
that situation if you do play this a
five a 4/9
a five let's say you put your knight on
v3 and then where would the bishop is on
g2 this bishop can mmm let's let's look
at it like this so you do get to get to
your knight on a five where would you
place this Bishop are you gonna try and
play e5 and bring your Bishop out from
this side because even if you do manage
to play e5 let's say you play Castile
rook e8 and you play e5 you still if you
do bring this Bishop out - that's the g4
f5 this b7 pawn is always a little
Wiggly because and this Bishop on g2 is
constantly looking towards your queen
side so the best way the most logical
way that you could just block this idea
that white bishop on g2 is looking
towards your your queen side is you can
play b6 Bishop g2 Bishop e7 now you also
have some ideas with maybe taking
immediately so you're kind of forcing
your opponent to make a stop because if
b-tree right now you could consider
taking because this knight is pinned
so now but White has to make sure it's
Castille that was gonna kind of an only
move because of the pan
you mean theoretically you could just
play rook e1 or e3 but it will still be
pinned and you have to make castle so
now another move to think about just
because your opponent made castle you
shouldn't immediately castle you can't
think about another move that's also
good and follows with your plan
you're not going to rush to put your
king in itself safe place nobody's
attacking it just yet so that's why
maybe take a few seconds and see what
you're comfortable with if you do want
to make a sale or if you want to go and
follow with the plan of putting your
knight in the South post I was I wanted
to slight and be three really bad so I
just played a for Luke c1 now Knight a5
now it's it's a matter of for what if
white doesn't do anything like give me
two moves three moves I'm gonna play c5
I'm gonna try and stabilize this pawn
structure over here and then I would put
a rope I wouldn't castle I would put
this stroke on f8 to c8 and I would
start attacking your c4 pawn so my idea
is if you give me a few moves I'm gonna
make Casto I'm gonna play c5 I'm gonna
put this rook to c8 and I'm attacking
this guy so the best way so now now that
you know my idea think about what is the
smartest way for white to not let me
play this sequence of moves
okay-y can play 92 stopping
three will take on PTO they can take
maybe white
I like that idea it's very solid I don't
I think what has something better than
just 92
because if 92 then white is kind of
already already giving giving up the any
chance of any sort of attack but on each
side so my idea is to play c5 I want to
play see if I was black yeah that's the
idea
that should be at least one of the
candidate moves that you could consider
so I think you your two candidates
should be 92 and c5 my opponent chose to
play c5 which I think was the best move
because it gave me some troubles I have
to play 9th Petry because if I start
taking out c5 let's say for example I
take c5 you take back I do I think I do
have to exchange the Queen's off and
then this I think white is better in
this position white has no weaknesses or
as I have this week a four-pound well
the db2 pawn is also kind of weak but
I'm not planning and attacking it
anytime soon
I can't take this because my c7 pawn
would be extremely weak and next if it
were white over again white with hopes
like the exchange these pawns off and
put and put the fruit on c7 so taking is
not a real option Knight b3 your order
do you following with the plan you're
placing your knight in the place that it
belongs
now if white would see if y-yeah would
simply move the rook anywhere you have
the option of taking with either D or B
and as soon as white would take back you
would take back with the night so now
for white think a little about making
candidate moves and choosing between
them
so we said to think about moves with
checks takes which don't really exist
here well then the takes are these which
are not really worth considering more
than a few seconds and then we thought
about we should think about Musa threats
the the one will be the clear threat is
C six that should be one of the
candidates and the other candidates
should be moving up the rook because
that's the one that's under attack and
between Roxy two and c66 definitely wins
well wins the contest between c6 and
Roxy - so because it works C - you just
take and take with the Knights or with
the D pawn does that childrens really
matter and you would enter an endgame
with a pawn up and should be enough for
clear advantage so in this situation my
opponent plays c6 which was the best
move now to start making don't start
calculating start making candidatos your
what should you candy it moves out
gloppy
and
yeah don't start calculating just have
these if you see a move that is a clear
blunder in one move then yeah that's off
but if it's not a clear blunder then not
see one should be a candidate because
you went after night c1 there is this 92
that's a fork and there's the Queen so
it's worth considering but after further
consideration let's say if you take
night c1 takes you end up with well to
pista so but it is important that you
consider it because let's say if you
your King has already made the castle
then this night C one would be the
winning move because after there after B
would take in this situation if your
king as black was already in castle then
the B takes a eight making a queen
wouldn't have won
so mister basics oops here which is a
six is the best move and the idea that
Bishop a six is that you're attacking
you're putting your bishop in a better
place you're attacking the rook and
you're attacking the pawn so what
options are pretty limited
what has does something to protect the
rook and the pot so Juke c2 is the clear
because if you play Rickey one I mean
you can't consider it but in this
situation tricky one
you would just as White's you would just
be pinning yourself think internally
because you can't really move the pawn
and you can't really unlock to 110 so
after a bit of 86 the Roxy - now it's
important that you you can decide you
can think about both the Jewish Buddhist
eyes and think what are the threats what
is white one who does black one ideally
black would wants to eventually play d5
for a Bishop c4 and cut off the
communication between this Queen and
rook with this pawn so that's the ideal
situation but it's far from reality at
this situation what would what would be
the ideal pawn structure situation for
white
as black I want to play d5 I want to cut
off your communication so as white you
would want your pawns to be yes so
that's the ideal situation so what's
next move should be clear regardless of
well not regardless but logically white
would want to play rook you want a rook
to e1 and start pushing
efore d5 so that's why it makes few
moves Castle I mean I have to make
Castle at some point so castle white
played rocky one with the idea to play a
45 so now it's important because if you
if you rush it if you play d5
immediately there is this gnarly net if
if I've that's gonna come pin like [ __ ]
you here and I mean technically yes you
could play with d8 and if there is a 97
there could be Queen takes and it would
it would give more opportunity to white
then you should so eventually if you do
get to play this d5 you would want this
trip to be on d6 attacking this pawn
knowing that you can give one of your
candidate news because here you don't
really have take sort Reds so another
way to make candidate loses where do you
want your pieces to be it's like making
solving a puzzle if you want this part
to be on d5 you want this work to be 96
you don't you shouldn't just play d5 and
let your opponent have the chance of
playing 94 you can easily play rook t8
first and now white hands point 95 so
now you would want to play d5 and 56 and
attacking c6 and following with the plan
so
efore why don't support defect this is
you gotta play d5 this is it shouldn't
even be a question so you have to play
the files back now well for white demos
to consider is taking pushing and 95i
I'm still considering maybe 95 to have
been more that devalues one of the moves
that you have to start calculating
because if 95 then you have to if you
take then the d4 pawn is under attack
and you could technically take back with
the rope but the the dynamic position
would start to change because now black
is the one who's opening up rather than
white and but I'm still if I were white
I think I would have given 95 some
serious thoughts 85 students really
being in the in the mix of chemicals
that deep cause first of all you can
always take with the rook and then the
d4 pawn is kind of just Wiggly here so
the trivial is the two realistic
candidates were white be five and ninety
five my opponent chose to play e5 now
not a question that white should ask for
what is so my next move after I save my
Queen somewhere would be I want to play
Bishop c4 and then I want to play b5 and
then I want to establish that structure
and I want to start attacking your c6
pot so the question for white is how to
not let my bishop get to c4 and knowing
that let's say if you play queen a7
how can white prevent this Bishop c4
yep
so if I'm I can't believe a sub C for
anymore I could exchange it off or I
could try to plea b5 and keep this
Bishop here but this kind of looks like
a tall palm so I think in this situation
ideally well realistically you kind of
have to trade it off and then your
pieces aren't are kind of uncoordinated
because you still have good chances you
could try and move you to the rook start
pushing here and things could still
happen but it's not that strong clear
plan that you had that's whack so after
a five think about so you know your
opponent's next one was kind of bishop
of fun regardless of what you do well
after you move you're clean
so think about when Bishop if fun
happens this Knight is losing one of its
protectors so and if you do get to play
Bishop c4 and say [ __ ] of a fun Bishop
c4 you should take c4 d takes c4 Queen
would want to take c4 right so if the
Queen would want to take on c4 then this
Knights would again be unprotected
because the bishop is already exchanged
up and the queen is on c4 so in this
situation your candidate goals are clear
you only have three logical moves
Queenie 726 and queen f5 how to choose
between them some might say 27 is like
you could do Queen e8 and keep attacking
the pawn and Queen and five might be a
little too much because you can't come
back to e7 on this side anymore but
that's so between those candidates we
looked at 27 of after Bishop if one
blacks plans kind of don't work anymore
so if Queen a5 mister with one now
what is the difference between having
the Queen to e7 from 2 to f5 the
difference is the attack on this night
so in this situation you do have this
Bishop f4 so sorry
ships e4 so you should see for if white
decides to exchange it off you have this
b5 coming up next and the pawn on c6 is
already planning for his funeral
so after Bishop c4 black has a clear
plan you want to play b5 and you're
gonna go for this pawn the way that
white could think is well first of all
white has to kind of defend this night
that's why I think my opponents played
rookie tree b5 stabilizing note that not
Bishop over there hear my opponent came
up with a very interesting plan it might
be kind of hard for some of some to see
I didn't see it in the game I caught up
on it when it was happening but so black
white still ideally wants to force black
to change off these bishop without
having to take it so oops
white wants to create some some sort of
situation that this bishop would be
strange off at this bishop so keeping
that in mind my opponent did some
desperate rice here some knight is for
queen g4 I'm going for the first rank
weakness so he just went back and I in
this situation I realized that this jerk
is doing absolutely nothing over here
and that it would be more useful in b8
so that's what I did
my opponent here my opponents came up
with a form of plan that that if he
managed to execute it I would lose my
queen
it was between either losing my queen or
having to exchange off the bishops
willingly from my side moving my c4
bishop so take a few minutes in three
seconds and see if you can come up with
this
so let me give a hint first of all Kim G
- and I followed up with my plan to
attack the c6 pawn all right now this is
the situation now come up with the three
move plan that you are trying to
completely clear my Queen off the board
are you looking at h3 radiation I of g43
just a sufficient degree
yes I know because you have the moves
right but not the move order because if
white starts playing h3 g4
it creates some weakness that
potentially I could start exploiting
yes exactly it was very smart of him I
didn't catch it in the game as after he
played Bishop d3 oh yeah
Bishop d3 was brilliant you are taking
away these two squares that's my queen
has and your idea to play h3 queen is
five only move g4 by by Queen so I have
to take Bishop d3 if someone can come up
with a better move down Bishop d3 please
set me up alright so I had to probably
should be three Queen takes tea tree I
thought maybe rook tea tree but look if
rook to e3 maybe I had something like
Queenie for or if Luke tea tree maybe I
would play district to b6 anyways going
to Gandhi 395 I'm directly attacking
this pawn and I'm also planning to play
Knight c4 to again cut off the
communication to this pawn who came to
c5 Knight goes to c4 so my idea here is
very simple I'm gonna keep putting
pressure on the CC pawn but the problem
is even if okay one step at a time right
now I'm attacking the bishop the rook
and the pot so you have to put a rocket
that's not really a question at this
situation a situation if I do play
something like with p6
I can never really take this c6 pawn
because my b5 pawn is always under
attack with your rope so that's not
really that's kind of out of the
question so
try and make some candidate moves and
then we'll go over why I did what I did
what are you can do yeah what else
okay so your are you're just focused on
trying and bringing the opening up here
all right I'm not entirely sure how much
worse considering it is but I thought
maybe something like when g6 should be
worth considering maybe just to try and
exchange off the Queen's but this coin
is kind of strong over here and my queen
is not really doing much that's not bad
at this in the game I just had it I just
had the idea in mind that if if I do get
a chance to exchange the Queen's off I
should consider it more seriously
because my queen is kind of cut off from
the rhythm of the game that's happening
in the Queen side so I did fight before
indeed it's time for the breakthrough
and so if white would have taken
I would just take it back and I'm still
attacking the pawn over here I'm
assuming something like when c3 would be
played and um I think I would play with
me six or maybe even rook b3 trying to
again push the Queen further back whoops
and then again this guy over here so the
question would be how can Y defend this
and I don't really see any clear ways
so maybe that's why my opponent didn't
take it what my opponent did all right
let's take a second and look at it from
white side so what what is the best
course of defense for white I was like
ssin but it's kind of defense at this
point
or something that if why it doesn't do
anything if it's my turn again I'm gonna
take B takes a 3 B takes a three-drug p3
attacking you're clean and when you move
the Queen your knife goes bye-bye
so knowing that you can either try to
relocate my clean or you can try to
really catch your knight
that's why
can you can Davos
well we have one online sure yeah that's
what I thought history should have been
definite speak and it move because if h3
if I do play Queen as five there's
always g4 if there's Queen g6 and if Y
trans managed to get the Queen's off the
board I think White's position is is
still pretty uncomfortable and as black
I have way better chances of winning but
back but at least right now why doesn't
have to worry about it we king or
there's ideas of me taking victory and
rook taking a three and rugby tree so I
mean it's used as what your rook is
extremely misplaced over here and kind
of trapped so that's a story is
definitely a move worth considering for
white because white doesn't really have
much option I mean it's kind of is when
she moves it's either h3 that you should
consider or something like 92 that's
what my opponent did in the game he
played 92 his idea was pretty clear he
wants to take away this strong night he
wants to exchange it off and he also
wants to not let me play this through
Petri if if I do take on a tree now
right now this knight is pinned so I
can't really take on b2 so you have few
options first candidate goes
check stakes treads
well I kind of think the making candles
in this situation is not that hard
because you don't really have that you
can't really move this night you could I
think you should give it a few seconds
to think about the sacrifice but you can
immediately almost immediately see that
it's completely wrong and it's not going
to work but it's worth considering it
and candidate news are just a moves
worth considering and another you have
to be quick because if as black you just
try to improve let's say you play with
p6 or something like that
the Knights get exchanged off you lose a
pawn and it's the position can turn
pretty quickly so that's why I took take
I took on a tree that should have been
your one of your candidate balls and the
best way to think about it is what can I
do this is a baby Queen over here that
the white can try and take it off or
white could try and take c4 there are no
viable checks in this situation so don't
even bother with them but the takes are
this one is a viable one taking the pawn
back is the valuable one I don't really
see anything else that should be worth
considering that because some kind of
making a queen over here so
let's think about what if 9c for if not
c4 would you play a 2 a 2 would you play
rook p3 would you take back these are
this
these are solve the candidate whose but
you can try and sort them out switch it
takes first and the treads and take a
little bit say and think what would you
do after 94
we takes
I like it but I think kind of the only
move is rookie one
you could think about something like
rugby to take i-64 p1
I like it but I think it's might make it
unnecessarily complicated
well if Queen takes
there is also this rugby - I think
because if rook takes peaches he takes
with you you can't this is what done and
if the rook doesn't take back
let's say if you don't take the rook my
next one is going to be either a tree
depending on what you do or I have a
check here that I'm making you clean and
if you don't take back if you say let's
say do something like this I always have
the Queen exchange offering to exchange
the Queen's off and then I have a two
and this should be winning so also if
they take back with the rook there's
always this - baby Queens and so he did
not play Knight c4 in the game but for
Wyatt
those are the moves that you should
consider that you should think about
Knight takes e4 you should think about
me take a tree and those seem to be your
only two viable candidates so we take
say three now it's black what do you do
you don't have the rupee 3ne more and
your night is be under attack of being
exchanged and also paint
so the best way to try and make a
decision of how you want to think about
it as black is well you kind of have to
you kinda have to come up with something
that keeps your knight on the board
because this Knight is extremely strong
it's cutting off the rope and it's kind
of dominating the position so the best
way to keep your knight on the board
think about it like this
your knight is pinned and the best way
to keep your knight is to pin his Knight
back
how can you pin this Knight
yep
both nights are penned but this pin is a
stronger for black because white can't
really get rid of it that easily the the
best way that white tried to get rid of
it was with f3 cutting off the
connection between the attack of the
Queen to the rook now don't think about
crazy moves no need for making
sacrifices just yet as black just think
about making candid news keeping your
pieces and keeping pressure on your
opponent's what would be your candidate
news
thinking about takes and checks just
briefly considering them there is not
much reality to it because my tasty to
cook tasty to taking stuff with the
Queen and it's not that realistic
most of it is blender anyways so the
other move is making a threat and
attacking the defenders so this queen is
the big defender the d3 queen is
defending the rook which is pinned and
the night which well tonight spins so
you should immediately think about queen
g6 taking off this Queen exchanging
after screens would mean that this night
would fall immediately so here black is
winning and my opponent tries to come up
with some creative ideas just to kind of
trick me so I'm gonna flip it again as
white what's with that tricky move be
what is your best chance of tricking
your opponent's
to review briefly if you take it's
winning for me for black because this
night is complete depend and you can't
move it next move I'm gonna pick it up
and your queen doesn't really have
anywhere to go because if you go to c3 I
would most likely simply play something
like route B six or I would hunt your
queen
I want the Queens to be exchanged and
that's what I'm going for
so after queen g6 what is what's they'll
move for white to try and like one last
try to trick opponent
yeah that is kind of the last try
so after 94 as black again you start
thinking what takes check checks takes
here they're all the same and so the
moves that you should be considering is
definitely rook takes you to definitely
taking on e4 but you can kind of
eliminate both of them immediately rook
takes each you it takes away all of your
attack and your knight is a still pinned
here they D takes e4 there is this Queen
c4 which would continue attacking your
rook over here so ideally you would want
to take on e4 take on c4 and then have
this take on f3 but if do you do manage
to let's say if you do manage to get
this there is always going to be more
what could most likely hold this even if
you give some check here there is maybe
clean d3 and you don't you don't have
enough material to attack this rook is
under attack so the best way for black
to continue is to play group III you are
attacking this idea you're following up
at the idea of taking me for I'm taking
f3 for your next move you guys have a
new queen the queen has to go somewhere
so the Queen my opponent replace 21
because I mean what else can you do at
this situation and I took on e4 and I
believe he resigned yeah because if even
if he does take on c4 there is this I
take on f3 and I should be able to win I
broke up right so
that's what I had for today I had
another game but it doesn't really get
to and I hope you enjoyed it for me
again it's was a big stepping stone when
I started asking myself these questions
middle of my game so hopefully after a
few lessons here you would be
comfortable enough to automatically ask
yourself questions during the game what
does my opponent want hit my opponent
did this why how how can I not let him
do it and stuff like this so till next
week
[Music]
you